are we rolling right now we're good
hello i am rolo tomasi for valuetaining
questions
and this is a interview with an author
hi my name is rola tomasi uh these are
valuetaining questions with an author of
the rational mail
what made you get into writing i got
into writing back in really the
mid-2000s i was a
forum moderator of a forum called so
suave and a lot of the
conversations we had from about 2002 up
till about 2012 ended up becoming blog
posts in my blog the rational mail right
around 2011
and then right around to 2013 i had
people telling me i really needed to put
it into a book and so that's i kind of
fell into authorship i realized that uh
there was more material and i needed to
do what's now a five book series of the
rationalement how did you come up with
the name roloff i stole it
it's uh rolo tomasi is actually a
character that is in a movie called la
confidential rollo fun fact yes and he
is the reason i took it is because the
character it's not really a character
he's just uh implied in uh in the book
la confidential as well as the movie
which is a great movie go check it out
1997 russell crowe wasn't it i chose it
because the uh character or the name
role of tomasi was given to the guy who
got away with this crimes
and during that time
and really even today if you're
dealing with cancel culture or anything
else the kind of material that i deal
with it feels criminal how has your life
changed since writing the rational mail
quite a bit it's changed in the sense
that
things have become a little bit more
complex when you're working in a
day-to-day job
it's uh it's nice to have that regimen
and that routine and you know what
you're doing you know who you're doing
it for today
it's nice to have the freedom but i've
got more responsibilities now than i've
ever had before and i'm a one-man show
what was life like before youtubing and
podcasting
uh shall i tell the children what it was
like before the internet uh
youtube is has bee has evolved into uh
something that everyone can do it's
really how are we going to communicate a
message and i think it's a whole lot
easier now than it ever was before i
could not be an author
uh in
i don't know 1996
whereas today
anybody can be an author print on demand
kindle amazon
if you weren't a writer what else would
you be doing uh playing in my band
which is what i'm doing
i play in a band called trial of
ascension uh we have eight songs out
right now i got
what two four song eps on spotify i'll
probably be doing that
if not i would be doing something
creative
certainly graphic design or art or
helping other people get their podcasts
off the ground i i have proteges right
now so i would probably get into um
i would kind of like be a a record
producer of people who are
uh
podcasters themselves if you could
co-write a book with any historical
figure who would it be and why as an
author i would love to
do something with somebody like jack
kerouac or ernest hemingway like people
whose voice whose author's voice that i
really like i would do that just so i
could learn along with it
as far as content is concerned um
there's a few people i can think of like
dr warren farrell would be one of them
oh i can tell you here it is
dr god sod g-a-d-s-a-a-d
if you're watching this i would love to
co-author a book with you
it's the craziest bet you've ever made
oh the craziest bet i ever made was that
kamala harris was going to be the
president uh
by uh august of 2021
and i made that bet with uh john from
modern life dating and everybody who
knows who john is they'll they'll
realize that i bet him like 350 bucks
that it was going to happen before
august 1st and it didn't happen what's
the weirdest thing you've ever eaten
um i guess umi you know what uni is it's
sea urchin
it's sushi
it's uh it's actually pretty good if you
but i mean i don't drink anymore but i
used to drink
and you have to be a couple beers in
before you have some uni but if that's
probably the weirdest thing i've ever
had is sea urchin who would you want to
play you in the movie of your life
mark wahlberg because we look a lot
alike or uh brett favre
uh or chris jericho chris
would you rather have three eyes or
three arms i feel like i got three eyes
already um three arms then i could play
guitar a little bit differently would
you rather never gain weight from junk
food or never get hangovers from
drinking well i don't drink anymore
anyways so uh i would like to never gain
weight from uh eating junk food
especially zingers they did
would you rather here just any language
or be able to talk to animals talk to
animals i think um
because i have a i have two greyhounds
and i would love to be able to talk to
my greyhounds what's your guilty
pleasure
abba
[Laughter]
uh steel panther i think those are my
two guilty pleasures
what's the random stat of your life that
you would want someone to know well i'm
5 11. i think not enough people realize
that whenever i'm standing next to tall
guys people think i'm a manlet the thing
i'm like this tall like i'm hanging out
with guys like uh
like uh adam's a good example of this as
well but like uh when i hang out with
the kiyosakis like robert kiyosaki or if
i'm with george gammon or some of these
other guys that i hang out with i don't
know why it is that this industry
attracts some very tall gentlemen but
i'm 511 and these guys are like six foot
three so every time i take a picture
with them i'm like
this this tall next to them so i want
everyone here's a random stat i'm
actually five foot eleven thank you hot
feminist or overweight red pill chick oh
jesus hot feminist
because i could i could turn her would
you rather be with aoc or sarah huckabee
sanders oh hey aoc because i could turn
her
thank you for watching valuetaining
questions with rolo tomasi be sure to
check out my latest book which is the
player's handbook it is the last in the
series of the rational mail is available
today on amazon in print and in kindle
and the audible book is coming soon
[Music]